So that's it. I told you I've been my restless leg syndrome.
I gotta catch it, dude.
I gotta catch it when I catch it is the main thing I gotta catch it.
This is how fricking much of a guy I am.
I have restless leg syndrome.
I finally figured out after like six or seven years of having restless legs,
that the only thing that cures it, and this is not a joke is having an orgasm.
That's the only thing that cures it. Okay. It's the only thing that cores it.
Now,
I don't want to be talking about this because I don't like talking about jerking
off and stuff like that, unless it's in my comedy act. Okay.
Unless I'm making jokes, this isn't a joke.
Having an orgasm is the only thing that helps my restless leg syndrome.
I know my family sometimes it's this podcast. I'm sorry, but it's the truth.
Okay. Now I don't that much.
I just don't. I don't, I never really have it. Hasn't been my thing.
It always feels kind of weird to me nobody's around and I'm just,
you know, but I will say when I have sex and I have an orgasm, I'm very quiet,
but I am really dramatic and loud when I'm by myself, masturbating Ave areas.
And that's what I really pumped.
Oh, Oh, Oh yeah.
That's me by myself. All right. But when I'm quiet, it's like,
I'm trying to Rob a bank,
like after hours.
Okay.
Dipping through the lasers. So, um,
I found out that one time I at a loss, I was like, you know,
my, my legs were going nuts. And I was like, ah, it.
I guess I'll just do this pass some time I did it.
And then immediately did it again.
The next night perchance immediately passed out. You know,
this I've talked about this. Okay.
Now it's become my kind of like my nightly thing.
But here's the thing. Okay.
I don't want to be jerking off.
This is how much of a guy I am.
I'm in bed trying to go to sleep.
I can't fall asleep and I'm almost asleep,
but my legs are buzzing and I'm like, come on, man, just please fall asleep.
I don't want to have to wake up and jerk off like straight up.
And then I'm like, I guess I have to. Cause I just can't.
I just can't fall asleep. And then when I wake up to do it, I got to get,
you know, I want it to be quick. So I'm not gonna use my imagination because
men are visual.
So I start watching porn and I try to do it as quick as possible.
And then I'll do it. And then once I'm done, I'm so tired.
And I just started watching porn more and I'm not even into it
genuinely because the things that take me out
are
the titles of the porns like you got me thinking about it. Oh,
that got me thinking about the one. Uh, last time when I said,
suck me off the completion. Like when they all make it grand, you know,
like every here's what title, every porn should be
or sucking or riding
or eaten. You know what I mean?
Why, why is it eating? You know, you're not swallowing. It,
you're not chewing it. So gross. You know,
this is the after hours is why is at the end of the podcast,
but the way their porn's titled is just so dumb,
dude, all of them like this, this,
these are like adults uploading these and making the titles petite teenager
gets horny for a big,
you know, like a 45 year old wrote that. Here's another one.
Bodybuilder stud has his way with this petite team spinner
set disrespectful.
Teen spinner. I mean, dude,
ah, this one hot, big boobs.
Brunette peed herself after a hot sex and full load cream pie.
[inaudible] so many different titles in one. That's the transformer of titles.
Hot, big boobs, brunette,
Peter self-transforming hot sex and full load cream pie.
Roll out. I was by day. I'm a,
this is my porn. Hot, big boobs, brunette, peeing, transformers
out hot sex and full load cream pie. Too many.
It should just be dude. Big boobs, remit, peeing,
herself, eat hot sex, full load cream pie.
Childish. Here's another one. Big teen,
big teen almost caught at the mall.
Risky public sex, dude. I love how it's
it's so crass and simple,
but also they'll add a little flavor to like and get descriptive.
You know what I mean? It'll be like big boobs
at a wonderful water park.
Big boobs at a wonderful water park
here, here. Here's another one here. Anytime they use interracial. It's like,
what are you? What are we? Scientists?
Curly haired filled up multiple times by interracial Dick.
Like get so, you know, get so,
what do you call it? A specific
and then the cartoon. Hey, who's watching the family guy porn.
What? straight up loser in cell. Yeah.
Peter Griffin. Lois
as he's busting a nut. Okay.
I don't understand.
Look at this two Cox one mouth blow job. Slutty. Young cheerleader. Swallowed.
Double com. Got all the keywords there, huh?
God dude. Anytime they're just so crass. When they use the word like drilled,
not drilled, you know
the step brothers step son, step mom. is just, Oh,
here's my favorite one. Wow. Look at this one. It's called true anal.
Like that. Like that would be a on HBO.
True anal tonight at eight, they don't need alone barrel. What's the
what's that HBO theme
theme. What's the old one.
[inaudible] wasn't that? What? It was true. Eight Oh
HBO feature presentation. Dan, Dan, Dan alone.
Dang. Dang. True. Anal followed by basic instinct
here. Here we go.
How does this? Oh, they had like a whole thing. I forgot about this.
I forgot about this. They'd zoom over the city.
1983 opening credits or they got rid of this.
Nobody gives a about this. That's hilarious.
[inaudible] tonight at eight.
Body builders stud has his way with this petite team spinner
tonight at eight hot, big boobs,
brunette peed herself after a hot sex and full load.
Dude.
Wow man. Wow. That's funny, dude.
Wow, dude. I can do that all day long.
Wow. I'll do more. It's my podcast. you.
Here we go. Do it. Here's more. I'm just reading porn titles, doing the HBO,
doing the HBO
hippy team. Trespassing bucks security.
Beautiful girlfriend. Can't swallow enough. I mean so awesome player.
Cougar, Shonda Fe,
by pink and body guy milk.
Step-mom said deuces teen daughter. Best morning.
Hand job from young hot girlfriend with big come shot. Mini boom.
Mini boom. Not a boom. If it's men
booms or big dude. Wow, dude.
I'll do more. you, dude.
My podcast 21, six cream. I'll call you later.
My step granddaughter needs me.
She pulls him back to come inside cream pie Aussie couple.
Wow dude. This is the best the podcast has ever been. Big tips.
Chubby teen gang bang and DP.
Tonight at eight Chinese couplers with high physical.
You have a sex in swimming pool.
No dude. Are you kidding me? That's a real one.
[inaudible] are you me?
Oh my God dude.
It's the best podcast has ever been. Here we go. Good.
I just want to get
Chinese couples with high physical quality. Have a sex in sweat
sex. Hold on, hold on, hold on. I can do it.
Chinese couples with high physical quality have a sex in swimming pool
ex Kemira young mistress, passionate sex with her slave. Let's do it.
Fueling of a Rory school by birth massage parlor shape with cream bike
to wait. What is this?
[inaudible] students. 18 years old.
[inaudible] Oh man.
I got to the Asian version for some. What the is that dude anyway.
So funny when they do this blonde with amazing looks.
Give her feet different work. What?
God dude. Porn is just knows. No bounds.
Ah.
Young
Jesus crises titles, dude. I'll do.
Hot blonde milk. Aliyah sucks. and talks like a filthy.
Young girl satisfied in the truck.
Sailor moon by monsters. Then lay egg. Is that house fly? Wait a minute.
Wow.
That's a real one. Sailor moon puffed by monsters. Then lay egg.
Is that housefly
children exists.
Sailor moon by monsters. Then lay egg. Is that a house flight?
Yo, what the?
Oh, this is even older.
Whoa, this one's even older, dude.
This is amazing, dude. All right, dude. I mean, you know how long, how much,
how much longer? How much longer can we do this?
More more dude. It's my podcast. you.
I'll do more. I'll do more.
There's one just called good head. Gave up.
Cuckold husband watches his wife get by a stranger V-Day gift.
The was this. HBO was around in 1912. Jesus. These are old.
Blustery submission, four 40 Simona and Leo love their way.
Stepdaughter. Alexa Nova shocks her stepdad. Rodney Maura with her house.
Exhibition is growing shows, boobs and at the beach.
Multiple orgasm, horny milk cowgirl writing.
Bet you wish your girlfriend would do this public agent blonde Jordan prices.
Massive.
Oh, I almost passed out right there.
Reading a bunch of these is the move dude.
Here we go. More. Here we go. More. And then, and then I'm done.
Horny, schoolgirl, deep throat and mouth POV. After college Vixen,
she's always fantasize about having sex with a stranger pantyhose, encasement,
European escort removed the condom. So I just had to come in
as BBW thick gloves BBCO two little school.
Girls slept suck after school like Sonic Barbara and Rosa,
small tips. POG, April Addison has anal orgasms,
impossible loser fruit.
wow. And I'm never again.
In the Disney movie, but it's all good, dude.
You come to this podcast for the realness dude porn, title.
Red from HBO God dude.
Thank God we found that. Thank God we found that dude.